The simple,
experimental approach that Luria took, which is to take a population
of--
to take a bacteria cell and to grow a
population of bacteria that are descended from that cell in liquid culture, so that
you go from one cell to billions, all in a test tube full of liquid,
and then to spread those cells out onto a Petri dish that
contained the virus T1.
Normally,
if you put a lot of bacteria on the surface of a Petri dish which contains food for
them,
they will proliferate on the plate.
So you'll see lots of bacteria growing all over the surface of your plate.
And what happens though, if you coat that plate with this virus T1,
almost all the bacteria are killed,
as I said.
So you actually see, in contrast to when you have no T1,
there's actually almost no growth of bacteria on the plate.
But in a few places where a cell is resistant to this virus,
what will happen is that cell will now proliferate,
generating millions and billions of progeny,
which will form a mound of bacterial cells that you can actually see what's called a
colony, a round mound of cells,
which all derive from the original cell, that one that didn't get killed by the virus.
So in the induced model,
the prediction was that all the cultures would have,
let's say,
anywhere from one to five resistant cells.
While in the spontaneous model, he realized that
some of the cells,
some of the cultures , might have zero, some might have one,
and some might have fifty. So why did Luria think that these distributions would
be so different?
And the reason he thought they would be very different
is because in the induced model, the simplest one to start with, all the
bacteria that one is going to spread on the surface of the plate, prior to ever seeing T1,
are going to be sensitive to the virus because they've never seen the virus so they can't
adapt their genetic material in the absence of ever seeing T1.
So what one expects to see is on the surface of the plate
rare cells that have spotted the virus that have acquired the
trait.
So if one did a series of plates, one would expect that those rare events would happen sort
of at similar rates on the different plates,
so each plate would have the same number of mounds of cells, or colonies.
So if it was,
let's just give an example that it's one in a million
chance, and you put ten plates each which have
ten million bacterium on them,
then you would expect,
on average,
ten of the bacteria exposed to become resistant to the
virus.
Now,
if you-- in the spontaneous model where limitations are
happening all the time,
one could imagine that these bacteria are growing up, they're having mistakes in their
DNA or in the chemistry that's leading to mistakes to their genetic material,
some of those changes are going to cause the bacteria to maybe grow a little faster,
some are going to make them be a little bit different shape,
but there's occasional genetic change that is going to make them resistant to the virus.
And that can happen at any time during the growth of this culture.
So let's imagine that it happens when there are only 100,000 cells in the culture.
The culture has to go through a series of-- the cells in the culture have to go through more
divisions in order to generate millions of cells,
and that particular bacterium that's become resistant has the chance to make more of
itself.
It'll make ten bacteria that are now resistant.
And so the fact that the spontaneous change can happen
at any time during the growth of the culture, it's not confined to when it actually sees the virus,
you can see how you could get, in fact,
many more resistant cells in a culture than you might expect otherwise.
So Luria's results of the distributions of
resistant cells in the cultures was very skewed and not consistent amongst all the
cultures,
ruled out the induced model.
It was consistent with the results for the spontaneous model.
But in and of itself didn't predict the distributions,
as Luria originally figured out.
He just said that they should be very,
very skewed.
And so he called in his friend Max Delbrück to help him with the math,
to say,
can we develop a mathematical formula that will actually,
assuming they're spontaneous mutations, that will actually give rise to
the skewed distributions that we actually see?
So it was taking it from being just consistent, to in fact,
no, we can actually predict that the results are actually consistent,
that they actually show that this is happening by spontaneous mutations.